[Music]
well uh al rods i'm an agricultural
engineer with usda a agricultural
research service at university park
pennsylvania and what i'm going to talk
about today is a little project that
we've done over the past year looking at
whole farm assessments of nutrient
extraction technologies we're developing
a model that takes a better look at this
co-authors are colleagues of mine and
they include clint church who's well the
mastermind i guess behind the map x
system and we he had a talk yesterday on
that well as the theme of this
conference goes and every and we all
know um manure is a beneficial resource
it has value for the nutrients but even
more now as we look at the soil health
and organic matter carbon sequestration
it's all kind of tied together that
manure does have value but of course it
has its challenges and and a big one is
just a low concentration of nutrients
and fairly
on uniform often uh distribution of the
nutrients within the material our dairy
farms in particular getting larger and
larger and often that means more animals
per unit of land more purchase feed
bringing nutrients in
over applying nutrients onto the farm
and and build up of excess nutrients and
and we have nutrients we have to get rid
of so this has led to
the development and
you know there's a lot of work now being
a lot of thought being put into
different types of extraction
technologies that can be used on dairy
farms i've listed a few here i guess our
view of this was that you know it might
be good to have a tool that cannot
really look at
how these technologies will impact the
actual farm how do they interact with
all the other parts of the farm
and ultimately what are the production
costs in
the impact on profitability uh farm
nutrient losses
the resources particularly fertilizer
that have to be
brought in in conjunction with the use
of the technologies and that sort of
thing and we also want to look at some
life cycle impacts greenhouse gases of
course is a big one that gets a lot of
interest now and fossil energy use was
another one that we looked at so our
objective in this particular study was
to perform a comprehensive assessment of
phosphorus extraction in particular from
from dairy manure and we were using a
decanter centrifuge centrifuge for this
particular study
we're kind of using this as an example
of how we could implement this type of
technology in the model and
and do a whole farm assessment so the
model we're using is the integrated farm
system model
this is a
a tool that's been under development for
an application for many years we've used
it to look at a wide range of
technologies and strategies for
dairy farms and and beef production
systems so what we needed to do here was
just to develop a new component and put
into this model to represent these
extraction technologies
and again we tried to be pretty general
in in the formation of this model
so that it could be applied to
various technologies and then after
doing that then we wanted to look at how
it actually fit in to an actual farm in
pennsylvania and we looked at the farm
in two different ways first is the base
farm the way it is today the the farm's
in a in a long-term nutrient balance
basically there there's
enough land there we're producing enough
feed
to you know recycle all the nutrients
and then we wanted to look at what if we
were reducing that farm area some
and there was excess phosphorus that
they really needed to get rid of how
does that affect things a little more on
the model itself it is a whole farm
process level simulation
so we're simulating as shown indicated
here all the major components
of the farm uh looking at the flow of
nutrients in and out of the farm and and
among the various components
so it really does look at a lot of the
interaction so if you change one part of
the system how does it affect all the
other parts of the system the model does
predict various gaseous emissions
greenhouse gases ammonia hydrogen
sulfide and docs
also denitrification losses of
n
n2 n2o and no2 nitrate leaching
runoff losses of phosphorus and nitrogen
and so forth it does do
a whole farm balance of each of the
major nutrients as illustrated here with
phosphorus it kind of tracks all the
phosphorus in and out through the system
it also includes a cradle to farmgate
life cycle assessment as illustrated
here we have the greenhouse gases that
are coming directly off the farm
either enteric
from the animal and then the emissions
from the manure and so forth but we also
look at what we call the upstream
emissions those that would occur
as we
develop produce resources that are being
used on the farm uh fuel electricity
fertilizer and that sort of thing so
that's where we get the cradle to farm
gate everything that goes up to the
point where that milk leaves the farm is
accounted for as far as the extraction
component then
the technology can be used to extract or
export
whatever you the user defines as coming
out okay so it can be any combination of
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium again
we're trying to kind of general in the
way we set it up so it could represent
a wide variety of applications and by
setting entering the the initial costs
and and
labor prices and fuel electricity price
so forth it does do an economic analysis
to look at the the effect on on cost of
the farm and then of course it looks at
all the interactions as you change the
nutrient cycling how does that affect
crop production and various
environmental impacts of the farm so the
base farm that we're working with here
is an actual farm or where it's
representing an actual farm in
pennsylvania we have 2 000
hosting cows and replacements pretty
good
milk production rate of 24 600
pound per cow we have uh 34th
acres of crop land again that's enough
to produce all the feed essentially for
these animals and with a very major part
all the grain and forage so we're
producing alfalfa grass corn and rye for
the for feeding the animals the
lactating cows are maintained in
freestyle barns with a flush manure
system and we have a screw press that's
extracting the manure solids and they're
recycled as bedding something that's
maybe somewhat unique about our region
it's called the ridge and valley region
you can see here this you see the long
ridges and the long narrow valleys
between them so the a farmer this size
can really stretch out long distances
so they're hauling this speed for fairly
long distances and then of course
returning that manure
very long distances if they want to
redistribute that uniformly throughout
the farm so as an alternate then we
wanted to look at
something actually that the actual farm
is considering and that's to do away
with the flush system and go to a scrape
system
how does that affect the farm for one
and then the use of the centrifuge the
other was to reduce the crop land down
to 2 700 acres we got rid of any corn
grain production we bought and
brought in all the corn grain
and this created a a surplus of
phosphorus that had to be removed
so in terms of the the original farm
then
by using the centrifuge we were able to
reduce the hauling distance by about 50
percent and the number of trucks by
about 30 percent what we're doing here
instead of hauling all the manure out
to all the fields
we extract a large portion of the
phosphorus into a concentrated material
that can be hauled much more
conveniently to the outside areas
and it also leaves the remaining manure
with a higher end to pee ratio that's
more suitable
for the
areas close by the farm facility so
that's what we're really modeling here
and that's the impact so all that is the
annual fuel use in manure handling was
decreased 16
this was offset by 79 percent increase
in electricity to drive the centrifuge
and the pumps and so forth that are
associated with that
so over all the energy costs did
increase the annual cost of owning and
maintaining the equipment increase labor
costs decreased a little
uh
by the reducing the manure hauling time
all total
the manure handling costs increased
you know a little over 27 000 per year
here so wasn't an economic win with this
system with the better distribution of
phosphorus we did find a slightly less a
slight decrease in the phosphorus runoff
losses from the farm going to a screw
press then we were working with a more
concentrated manure because we weren't
recycling all that flush water so we got
by with one less screw press so where we
had two in the original farm it went
down to one this reduced the electricity
consumption energy costs
were reduced 24 labor costs increased 65
because
we were now using a scrape system where
in this case we were
using a skid steer or tractor to scrape
that manure
which required some labor overall the
manure handling cost did decrease nine
percent
slight increase in soluble p runoff
with this type of
system
while the sediment p runoff decreased
and overall the farmgate life cycle
energy consumption decreased about two
percent no real impact on greenhouse gas
emissions then when we put this the
extracting the centrifuge in with the
scrape system it was more economical
okay
uh we were able to get more efficient
extraction of the phosphorus for one and
then we were we greatly really reduced
the volume of material that had to go
through the centrifuge so electricity
use increased and fuel consumption
decreased as compared to without the
centrifuge
a little effect really on the
environment other than there was a two
percent increase in the farm gate
intensity of fossil energy use which
kind of offset what we just saw
that they
saved by going to a scrape system
equipment and labor costs reduced and
the centrifuge extraction
reduced the total annual cost by about
two thousand dollars a year so not it's
positive anyhow i guess it's pretty much
break even i i guess when you look at
the long-term in terms of the overall
cost of operating the farm when we went
to the
system that
with a smaller farm with access p that
we wanted to get rid of
uh use of the the
centrifuge we had to use it about eight
hours per day to extract the excess
surplus p okay the in this case
the model calculated that there was
around 16 500 pounds of p
that had to be removed from the farming
system to maintain a long-term balance
so operating it eight hours per day
increase the equipment electric energy
costs
with some small increases in facility
and labor costs to maintain the
equipment uh increase the annual manure
handling cost by
a little over or eighteen thousand
dollars a year so looking at what the
cost was to remove that pee
that comes out to a little over a dollar
a pound of pea removed from the farm so
you're ending up with this material that
really does have some pretty high value
as far as a pea fertilizer source and
maybe for other uses as well but
nevertheless the cost for remove for
producing that material is still more
than
the cost of just buying phosphate
fertilizers so perhaps for organic
markets and such you know it would be a
little bit more more economical so in
summary i guess use of the centrifuge
for pea extraction on the dairy farm
it really appears less feasible and
pretty
on economical when used with a flush
system just because of the sheer volume
of material that you have to re
continually recycle through the system
but with a scraped manure system
the increased extraction costs may be
more than offset by the reduced
transport costs you know we're looking
at these large farms where we have to
call it for long distances
as we saw it was it was economical to
to extract the peak by extracting
a significant portion of the p from the
from the manure you do end up with a
better end of p ratio in the remaining
manure
again it could be used close by where
you have this more concentrated pea that
can be transported longer distances more
efficiently and more cost effectively so
if you have excess phosphorus to get off
the farm you know centrifuge
provides a material with a high p
concentration that can be exported for
other uses but the cost of producing
that be if you're comparing it
particularly to fertilizer
you know it's it's not necessarily a win
but i mean again there's the organic
market and there's also more nutrients
left in this than just the phosphorus
too that we haven't really properly
accounted for so it does have more value
than just the phosphorus itself and of
course a cost that's really hard to put
a value on is the long-term potential
impact i guess of on eutrophication uh
you know so there is this long-term
reducing risk
you know for for eutrophicationary by by
pulling out extracting this phosphorus
and using it more efficiently so there's
a benefit to society there that's really
hard to put a value in so in conclusion
i guess this
this is primarily a research tool but we
feel it's it's it's a good tool that we
can be can be used to evaluate a wide
range of these different types of
technologies that can be used for this
particular study it had it was just
published in applied engineering and
agriculture if you'd like to look it up
and and get more detail on use of the
decanter centrifuge on a dairy farm
right thank you
is
the annualized capital cost on it on the
centrifuge and other equipment that was
being used
amortizing the the initial costs over
the lifetime of the equipment
and
putting that in with the annual cost
along with any electricity use and labor
total operating costs
[Music]